Marius hey listen to music all the time
he had an accident when he was a kid we
still got a humming the drum plays music
to drown it out that's what makes him
the best
you
aren't you mysterious
[Music]
there's business to the world consists
in the three things money big connects
[Music]
we gotta get blowed wait
I gotta start the song over okay go then
you tell me who died no I'm driving
[Applause]
sound music name so you just
starting your day or did you just get
off hey call I go you know so what is it
you do I'm a driver Oh like you're so
fur
anyone I'd know
ha what is your name favorite your
name's baby Bab why baby just one each
they listen to the music all the time
maybe a mental mental meaning slow was
he slow no he had an accident when he
was a kid still has a hum in the drum
plays music to drown it out and that's
what makes him the best
[Music]
for more job when I'm done one more job
and we're straight no I don't think I
need to give you the speech at all what
happens when you say no how I can break
your legs and tell everyone you love
because you already know that I am yeah
the moment you catch feelings there's a
moment your kitchen bully and your
waitress girlfriend sink you keep it
that way
I want us to head west and every stop
here when I'm in baby
[Music]
these days baby you gotta get blood on
your hands
conference music
baby can you get out of here I have to
end it are we in bed together now baby
baby
stock said Michael Myers dick Mike Meyer
it should be the Halloween man this is
the Halloween mask
no the killer dual from Halloween oh you
mean Jason no baby you tell me who does
you good girl you look inside you that's
too bad
you